[Musique]
500000 distro en 1900 en france contre
200 milles en 1960 les 36000 en 2015
les cafés français se meurt parmi eux
les fameux bistrot parisien dont on
déplorait déjà la disparition en 1975
les bistrots typique et enfin comme
celui ci simon gilbert le héros
disparaît le bistro parisien
c'est d'abord un symbole de l'art de
vivre à la française un endroit des
changes où les histoires se font au
comptoir 1962 les cafés du quartier
latin sont le lieu de rendez-vous des
étudiants à l'image du souffle aux un
bistrot situé à deux pas du panthéon
parce que j'aime aussi flosse et
rencontrer des gens qui font du droit
avec qui on peut on peut discuter
refaire le monde
l'instant à l'époque les premiers
messages de prévention contre
l'alcoolisme font leur apparition 1972
un arrêté préfectoral est pris à paris
les bars devront être espacées de 75 m
contre 3 auparavant
une situation qu'ils avaient pu moore
par cette habituée il est préférable
d'avoir des bistrots qui se côtoient
comme the world et the big toe qui
paraît-il actuellement son qu'il ne qui
paie par des gens non malades car
pasteur a dit la meilleure des boissons
et le vin les années suivantes
la situation ne s'améliore pas pour les
cafés de la capitale les lis trop
continue de s'effacer du paysage
parisien
les clients déplore la perte du lien
social on trouvait beaucoup de cafés où
tout le monde se réunissent et pour
jouer à la belote
ça se perd de plus en plus j'aime bien
jouer on préfère tous les cafés vient
ensuite la concurrence des fast food à
partir des années 80 les bistrots sont
boudés des étudiants en à une clientèle
plutôt couteau âgé qui a l'habitude de
venir ici et les jeunes viennent de
moins en moins noire des cafés parisiens
traditionnel délaissé par la jeune
génération au contraire d'établissements
plus moderne avec du wi fi des canapés
et des espaces pour travailler
comme les cafés traditionnels ou
pour ce sens on se sent pas très bien on
envie de voir un café de partir à ces
huit là on a envie dresse un peu plus
avec la crise sanitaire
la situation ne risque pas de
s'améliorer pour les bistrots parisiens
selon un sondage 10% des cafés de la
capitale sont restés fermés en juin
dernier
malgré l'autorisation de réouverture
[Musique]